[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I
know change
I
all right welcome everybody obviously
Stephen is out today but don't worry I
am here taking the rains I don't do the
Sip like he does it because just be
honest I think maybe I would choke on
accidents and and spit water out and you
know we we don't want to do that on a
live show everybody's going to know it's
never going to go away it's just going
to live on forever but just remember
this is a live show Monday through
Friday 10:00 a.m. eastern time uh we
will be here and I have a very special
show for you today I think you're going
to really enjoy the topics that we've
covered and let me just before we get
too deep into this let me just tell you
a little bit about some of the stories
that we've covered in the past that
really tie in directly to what we're
going to be talking about with our guest
today um we've repeatedly discussed the
negative impact of government overreach
and bureaucracy um we've done it when we
talk about the all the three-letter
agencies right the FBI the CIA um when
we talk about attorney general Merrick
Garland uh letter about the school Bo
boards and all the extremists these
concerned parent parents uh in Lowden
County was one of the big ones uh that
we all talked about but these concerned
parents at the school board meetings are
extremists and need to be treated as
such and then who can forget Joe Biden
going after Maga in front of the nazes
background with all of the red kind of
you know color behind him um it was
really bad Optics uh but you have the
president of the United States singling
out essentially half the country and
saying that these are people that we
need to be worried about this is
something that needs to be dealt with
these are extreme these are white
supremacists um these these kind of
labels and these things get thrown
around all the time and they they set up
a system where things can go very wrong
very quickly and I've talked to you a
number of times about other instances in
history where that's happened um in Nazi
Germany how they kind of laid the
groundwork for calling the Jews uh the
problem right and the solution being
well these people are subhuman they're
causing all of our problems and so
therefore the atrocities are Justified
uh or if you talk about it in Cambodia
with the camir Rouge they did similar
things to this like these people are
going to be the problem we have to take
care of all of the intellectuals who
want to keep us from becoming this
agrarian superpower uh that can rule the
world or whatever other group you want
anytime you other a group and make them
subhuman where they are a threat to
democracy during coid people who didn't
get the vaccine those are people that if
they go to a hospital they should have
to stand outside and die of a heart
attack because somebody else who had the
vaccine is taking care of themselves and
they should be treated Ed first like
that kind of thing you don't have a a
job you don't have a place to live you
don't have any ability to to travel
sounds a lot more like communist China
than it does the United States of
America um and he said Stephen many
times uh talking about this that
candidates that are running for public
office not just president but candidates
in general need to be ready to answer
the question on defunding the FBI would
you defund the FBI with all that we know
now uh and all that you're going to
learn today about the FBI and some of
the things that doing we need to get rid
of these agencies in their current form
and for a while we talked about reform
and we just feel like we're way past the
ability to reform but our next guest has
been uh unfortunately well acquainted
with government overreach and has
decided to release uh another movie uh
that I think is going to be really
interesting and pretty impactful uh and
a lot of fun to watch other than it
scares the hell out of you uh but here
here's some highlights of the uh new
movie police
state
we honor you father for all that you've
done for
[Music]
us Chief division Council and doj have
approved a no not
breach we want the subject to be on
display doing the Walk of Shame full
visual
impact any questions are we becoming a
police
state government told American citizens
they couldn't go to church on Sunday for
the first time in my life say to myself
am I going to get a knock at the door
FBI War come to the door now the Patriot
Act and fisa were used against Donald
Trump these individuals have
commissioned the biggest propaganda play
in US history they don't go after the
people that rigged the election they go
after the people that want to find out
what the hell happened we don't need to
have a crime what we need is is a person
to look at and then we go find out what
crime you did FBI our focus is Shifting
our main priority as a bureau is going
to be domestic terrorism really paints
anybody who's right of Center if you're
a pro-life pro- Family Catholic they
Define you as radical these are
anti-government we have freedom of
religion and freedom of speech violent
extremists and they must be dealt
with we can do anything we
want
[Music]
chilling stuff and uh if the cat's not
already out of the bag ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome our next guest
denes
[Music]
jza Danesh thank you very much for being
with us I know that you are probably a
very busy man right now doing the
promotion for this but thanks for being
with us here it's a real pleasure my
first time here and it's uh it's quite a
spot it's an experience when people come
in they're used to seeing Studios where
maybe it's a small room and somebody
gets in front of a mic and they have a
nice setup but this is a sprawling
complex essentially to do all the stuff
that we do we uh we discuss stuff like
this that will absolutely make your skin
crawl um and then we do other comedy
stuff where we have people dress up as
film characters and make fun and so we
we kind of it goes the Spectrum we're
fine with it but so let me really
quickly I just want to tell people where
they can find this right off the top so
police state fm.net is where you go to
get tickets for the premiere October
23rd and 25th now that's in theaters you
said you have around 700 theaters right
now Nationwide yeah we've bought out
hundreds of theaters and the cool thing
is if you go to the website put in your
ZIP code boom all the theaters around
you will pop up and then it's I made the
film for the theater so it's really fun
to see in the theater yeah but if you
can't see it in the theater then on
Friday October 27th we have a virtual
Premiere where you can watch at home the
full full screening of the film and then
a live Q&A with Dan Bonino and me to
follow and it's all for the price of a
movie ticket fantastic so on the virtual
Premiere do you still go to police uh
State film. net for that or yeah it's
the OneStop shop and that's important
because you can't go to the theater or
go to Fandango you have to buy the
tickets off the website so policestate
fm.net is the place to go fantastic all
right police state fm.net um also it'll
be available on Rumble and other
platforms and DVD uh after all of this
is done after the premiere and after the
uh October 27th uh Premiere from Las
Vegas the virtual Premiere so um tell us
just a little bit about this film right
so you you've obviously dealt with this
and I kind of alluded to that um tell us
kind of what made you think okay I need
to make a film about this and really
expose what's going on here was it your
personal interactions or was it that
plus more no I would say it wasn't it
wasn't my own personal case even though
I sort of got an early whiff of the
police state I got to say that in my
case which goes back to 2013 a campaign
Finance violation and I did exceed the
campaign Finance law I got to say that
up front but normally it's a offense for
which you'd get a slap on the wrist a
community service or a fine Rosie
O'Donnell did the same thing essentially
and did get the slap on the wrist well
Rosie O'Donnell did something actually
far worse yeah because what she did was
she camouflaged her contributions to
multiple candidates she knew she was
going above the limit because she kept
changing the spelling of her name um so
it was in one case it's R oal and it's
Rosie oonn and it's Rosie you know so
Rosie spelled with a Y she was trying
but not very hard but she in a blatant
way and see that's what they're looking
for is the intent to break the law which
was not true in my case I was giving
money to a college friend any event when
when my case came up I saw it as a
one-off because I had just made a film
about Obama you know I know the guy is a
is a vindictive narcissist and I thought
oh my gosh I should have known there's a
Target on my back
he's going to unleash Eric Holder and
his attack dogs I didn't see my case
then as being a Prelude or a precursor
to what would happened to Carter page
Papadopoulos Michael Flynn of course now
Trump so I didn't see the police state
coming with the the rapidity that it has
under Biden um I think the way I think
about it is I I flash back to when I
first came to America at the age of 17
as an exchange student this was actually
in the very late
1970s and as I learned about America you
know I of course en enjoyed the great
abundance of America and the
possibilities the upward
Mobility but I also learned that this
country is great because it's got this
Bill of Rights and you've got these
enumerated rights which are not open for
political negotiation that's the key
that's the meaning of unalienable rights
you can't give them up and majorities
can't take them away right to free
speech uh you know right to conscience
uh right to assembly to petition the
government equal rights and equal
justice under the law and so fast
forward to now and ask yourself is a
single one of those rights now
completely secure no every single one is
in Jeopardy and so the chilling question
pressed itself on me are we becoming a
police state and I thought that's a very
interesting topic for a movie so it's
not just about the FBI it's not even
just about the police agencies of the
government it's not just even about the
government our police state sprawls even
into the private sector it's a weird
octopus uh stretching across the private
and public sector both but the film
brings it home to you I think in a way
that nothing else can yeah well and I
you and I talked about one of my
greatest fears off camera I'm not sure
that I'm going to tell everybody but it
revolves around this and unjust
incarceration so nobody nobody come
after me for that but I want to read a
quote from you really quickly uh about
police state and so police state this is
the quote directly police state is a
movie um and actually let me going to
read it on here police state is a movie
that I never wanted to make because I
never wanted America to get to a point
where a movie like this needed to be
made I feel like the animal that alerts
the herd to approaching danger so we can
take precautionary steps before it's too
late um and I you know I think I think
that's fair because I've realized that a
lot of people that do stuff like you do
whe whether it's people who are out
there speaking up on uh Google right we
had Dr Robert Epstein in here uh kind of
felt like the same way and that guy's
the furthest thing from a republican
that you can probably imagine
supportting Hillary Clinton was
definitely somebody in in you know
Bernie's Camp if if Bernie would be the
nominee Joe Biden was somebody that he
supported as well but he saw something
that would tear at the fabric of our
democracy right uh our Democratic
Republic could not survive if a
corporation could do something like this
now we focused a lot on this show
talking about those big corporations and
the influence they have and you say that
this kind of is an intersection of all
of these different things it's not just
the three-letter agencies and the
government it's the private sector
sector as well and then one of the most
chilling things that we've seen
historically in societies that become
police States is your next door neighbor
gets involved because they've bought the
lie that if they don't turn you in
they're against the state they're
against what these values that these
corporations are espousing are so you
obviously like you said it wasn't
necessarily a specific moment that led
you to do this film uh but what is the
goal of the film what what do you want
to see happen I know you did 2,000 mules
and the goal there is much more clear
it's like okay we have to stop this
particular practice with elections and
we need to we need to make some Headway
there right got that that's pretty clear
what do we do here what's the goal well
the goal here is to do what I think a
documentary can do best which is to
raise a big question about Society to
frame it in the correct way which is to
say to frame it in a fair and Urgent way
to allow people to see for themselves
and experience an unfolding storyline of
phenomenon that really gets them to look
into themselves and talk to others and
think about it and then ask what can be
done about it so the film creates the
awareness without which people don't act
so for example A lot of people are going
to say you know I'm not Donald Trump I
didn't go in the capital on January 6th
I didn't get into big fights with the
cops I pay my taxes I'm a law- abiding
guy the FBI is not going to come to my
door toes and smash it in now I think
that guy could not be more wrong um and
and I even am approached by guys on the
left and they go well no one's Banning
me you know I'm not threatened by the
DHS and I go yeah but could that be
because you're helping to build the
police state in other words our police
state is it's not a full-fledged police
state yet in fact if it was a
full-fledged police state I admit this
film could not be made we wouldn't be
doing the show we couldn't be doing the
show I'd be turning you in right now
award or vice versa oh come on so anyway
but my point is that that um that we are
moving we are hurtling toward a police
state and uh and so the the line you
quoted from me being an animal giving a
warning too many Americans are like the
antelope or the wilderbeast that
basically goes oh yeah I saw that too
but it's just the wind inesh it's not a
predator in the trees or maybe it is a
predator but guess what I'm going to
hope it's not going to land on my back
maybe somebody else is back yeah so you
want to to raise the awareness um not
just of the Republicans we talked about
this beforehand too because I think the
the audience like our audience certainly
this should not be a surprise to them
right it'd be a very informative movie
but I see like a lot of head bobbing in
the theater if a lot of our audience is
there because they'll be like I this
just connects this lines up exactly with
what we've been talking about I get it I
understand it are you trying to reach
that broader audience because I I think
we believe that you have to have a
broader audience this can't be us just
singing to preaching to the choir the
whole time and I know the adages that's
how you get them to sing and that's fine
you want to mobilize people but at the
same time you have to to let other
people in this process know what's going
on how do you do that effectively um and
and really get across the whole
political boundaries well sometimes it
is is harder to do than at other times
so with my last film 2000 mules because
the topic was election fraud M the movie
came out at a time this was a year after
the 2020 election when people were
already dug in and so a lot of people
were like I knew it I'm going to see
this movie and it's going to validate
what I think and then there were other
people like I'm not going to see this
movie and in fact there were so-called
fact checks on the film bogus fact
checks but nevertheless they were like
we've seen this film so you don't have
to you know and and I'm sure a lot of
people are like yeah I'm not going to
watch that film because I already know
that this was the safest and securest
election in history so it was tough with
2,000 meals now police state on the
other hand I think can reach a much
wider audience because almost everyone
has a factual awareness that the things
I'm describing I mean let's look at what
we're talking about we're talking about
censorship I mean let's look at the
characteristics of any police State uh
let's North Korea Iran uh China the old
Soviet Union what what are those regimes
have in common well Mass surveillance of
citizens systematic censorship check Che
uh indoctrination in the schools and
universities and the media check uh
propaganda check um the police States
tend to be onep party States the not
that they don't have elections China has
elections Iran has elections but they
don't allow effective opposition right
they criminalize they try to lock up
effective leaders of the opposition
party check criminalization of descent
political prisoners so just go down the
list and you realize whoa not just most
all of the things I just mentioned are
now here in the United States now some
further along than others further long
than others much more obvious and the
the weird thing about this debate is
also that you will find people on the
left and you say do you think America's
becoming a police state and their answer
is denesh 100% but the perpetrator of
the police state is Trump or the
Republicans are the ones who are trying
to take away our liberties they're
trying to shut down abortion they're
trying to go after the trans so freedom
is interpreted in that way and using
that lens so the way I frame up this
film is a little original it's not just
are we becoming a police state but who's
right if there is a if we are moving
toward a police state is the threat
coming from the left or from the right
and I set up the film by saying all
right we can answer that question if we
know what is is a police state how it
got started how it's organized how it's
how it works and who's behind it and who
is in charge and once we know the answer
to those questions you'll know where the
threat is coming from and and you used a
lot of very um public examples uh of
this and honestly I didn't know all of
the details for all of this but the
there were a couple that struck me the
first guy that you used and I forget his
name you probably remember it who went
to January 6 had some footage
um and Joseph balanos yeah thank you he
so he went there had some footage never
went in never violated to my
understanding any laws that that you
would know okay well I'm I'm crossing a
boundary and I'm making the choice to do
that or or not he just was there had
some footage and was showing some
friends back at his bar based or not his
bar but at a bar he frequented and all
of a sudden a neighbor of his turns him
in so give us just a little bit of
insight into that cuz for me that was
one of the most average everyday
American stories this isn't like a
public figure this isn't somebody who
was kind of Skating On The Edge this is
somebody just happened to be there on
January 6 and in fact was quoted in the
movie as saying I started seeing guys
climbing the walls and I was like ah
something's wrong here I think I'm I
think I'm done you know I think I'm out
absolutely you got you know a
75-year-old guy who is walks with a cane
and um this is a guy who almost wanted
to be there just to just to be part of a
historic event so to speak he was
intrigued by Trump but he wasn't a
fullscale trumpster and he certainly did
not go inside the capital but this comes
back to what you alluded to uh a few
minutes ago about informance the idea of
your neighbor and of course in in police
States your wife you know your your kids
are calling you in and uh so a neighbor
calls him in but the remarkable thing
isn't just that someone felt to do that
um you know that that little tyrannical
impulse in all of us I'm going to get
this guy I'm going to be you know it
it's the mentality that makes one want
to be an aaric in a regime very
interesting psychology the other
interesting thing is that the FBI made
no effort to verify that this guy went
in the capital instead they deploy a
SWAT team and um you know and he's over
actually at his mom's house so they sent
two SWAT teams one to his apartment
where he wasn't and he They smash into
it he's not there then they go to his
mom's Rehabilitation Center
and they smash that place in and they
they get go arrest him there and then
they subject him to 6 or S hours of
interrogation in an FBI truck where the
guy is so flustered in fact he's
flustered in part because he sees NBC
showing up with the cameras and think of
it this is all coordinated isn't it they
they tip off the media they the public
humiliation is the name of the game here
and the guy has a stroke so all of this
this is what I think documentary do they
unfurl a narrative and the beauty of
this guy is he's a high-tech guy and
he's a little you know he's scared he
lives alone so he installed cameras in
his own apartment so he has direct
footage of what the FBI is doing and I
think very telling when the FBI comes to
his door they try to cover the camera
they don't want recorded footage but
they don't realize he has a second
camera and so we got the footage and
it's in the movie but it's it's very
creepy cuz you begin to realize it could
easily happened to you yeah absolutely
and look that's one of the reasons that
we got so frustrated with this whole and
not I'm not going to derail on January
6th but the January 6th hearings and uh
the Adam kinzinger and um um gosh I'm
losing her name LZ Cheney uh giving that
credibility when it was really just
political theater like it wasn't a real
investigation and two Republicans who
wanted to I guess be at the cool kids
table essentially gave something that
should have had no credibility
credibility and now not only do we feel
like maybe those guys that turned him in
felt like hey that's Justified he was
there maybe I am helping the government
catch a real criminal because I saw they
had hearings on this this was the worst
attack on Democracy in our country's
history and it was the worst attack on
on on us since 911 it was it was 9/11
part two essentially like people making
that equivocation and not immediately
saying well no hold on here's what
happened that's why it's so dangerous
because it sets the stage for everybody
to go you were there January 6th yes and
this is where a lot of conservatives
missed the point because they will say
what a ridiculous analogy this was not
an Insurrection you can't compare it to
the Civil War or even when Hillary
Clinton said very recently you know
these Maga guys are sort of cult guys
they need to be formally reprogrammed
now what's Hillary Clinton doing and
some people go well here she goes again
basket of deplorables no no no what
Hillary's doing is the same thing that
happened for example at Waco in the
1990s which is when you say that
somebody's an a cult and you make them
into being a complete weirdo you're
dehumanizing them for sure right and the
American people in the 1990s were
horrified when they saw all those
buildings burning at Waco but they were
like well it's not me those people were
Cooks they were cult members they were
up to God knows what and that's why this
happened so that's what Hillary's going
for she's trying to turn the political
opposition
she wants to dehumanize us as a as a
maybe a Prelude or um uh um a leading up
to incarceration and of course in the
Nazi case it was also extermination so
this can go down a very dangerous road
dark Road very quickly and and I you
know we're you're always careful using
the Nazi comparison right because people
say that and I say well look I'm careful
using it but it's one of the most
instructive pieces of history that we
have on how this can play out and if
people are uncomfortable with that well
let's go to the cir Rouge right I spent
some time in Cambodia and panom pen and
I saw the Killing Fields it was Sam
Waterton I think or I think that's his
name the guy from uh um now I'm
forgetting the name of the show H law or
there we go I always the the dun was
playing in my head I just couldn't think
of it he is in that movie and they
basically have a camp out in the the
rice fields kind of in the countryside
of Cambodia and they bring a child up to
the board and their stick figures drawn
the the board of two obviously parents
holding the hands of two children right
and the child walks up and is not given
any instruction but takes the Eraser and
erases the part where it's holding the
parents holding the child's hand
basically saying like I do not belong to
my parents I belong to the state right
and so kind of creating this if you're a
good citizen you are serving the state
above all else you are serving the
common good get your coid vaccination
Above All Else wear your mask and make
sure that you close down your business
Above All Else and these other people
will'll just drip we'll keep dripping on
these people so that eventually you
think of them as being kind of these
subhuman people it happened in Nazi
Germany the same way it happened in
Cambodia in pretty much the same way
it's happened in in countries in Africa
that have had these crazy um you know
the Killing Fields in kind of the same
way these people are subhuman and that's
why we push back on it uh but before I
get too far I guess down that trail
sorry I just uh it's just it really
irritates me when people
don't follow one of the most easy to
follow lessons in all of history which
is Nazi Germany in the 1930s like read
about the 1930s what was going on one of
the things we do in the film um with
that is we use an analogy to the Reich
dog fire now again when we're talking
about the Nazis there is Hitler Circa
1933 and that's really where I think the
examples are useful because Hitler
wasn't quote Hitler I mean in other
words you have didn't have the whole
Holocaust you didn't have the final
solution so when we think of Nazi
Germany we simult you know we tend to
think about the death camps and so on
but that comes later early in 1933
Hitler is the chancellor but he's not a
dictator yet and then what happens is a
foreign communist burns the Reich dog
the German Parliament and uh uh what
initially it's not clear who did it but
Hitler implies the dark conspiratorial
Forces forces did it in fact Hitler says
this wasn't Insurrection and Hitler says
we have to relentlessly go after the
people who did this and to do that I
need police Powers I need to suspend
civil liberties I need censorship and
all of this is then handed to him by the
German Parliament and then Hitler
becomes a dictator he becomes what we
now know as the opposition that's right
so so the Reich stock fire is
instructive historically because it
shows how an incident a real incident
can nevertheless be
manipulated uh used as AE pretext for a
widespread Crackdown and suspension of
civil liberty so I think this is the
relevance of January 6th yeah it was a
Reich stock fire event it's not that it
wasn't an event there was um but by by
uh manipulating the meaning of the event
and as you say the terminology of the
event you can then justify now we need
to ramp up digital censorship now you
can't even talk about a stolen election
because hey guess what you're one of the
insurrectionists um and so January 6th
in that sense becomes
a pivotal and I think for the first time
in our country's history in non-war time
we have political prisoners we've had
political prisoners in Wartime and that
we can talk about that but in non-war
time I can't think of good examples of
that and January 6th I think will be
seen historically as as a very ugly
first it it will absolutely and there
you know you're talking like 17 18
20year prison terms for people in the
Department of Justice coming back for
seconds now I don't know if you read
that recently I that's something that
should send kind of a chill down
everybody's spine who's watching this
you can think what you want to think
about what happened on January 6 but you
you think they should be getting more
prison time than a rapist when there was
anyway I don't want to get to far let
one you know one one further point on
January 6th because I think this gets to
the heart of the false narrative and and
I think this is an original point that
is made in the film namely this
according to the kind of January 6
committee's official narrative that
trumpsters went into the capital because
they were trying to stop an official
proceeding right what was that official
proceeding well according to the
narrative it was the certification of
the
election but if you think about it and
if you pay attention to what was
actually going on in that proceeding
that was not happening at all there was
a there was an official proceeding but
it was a different proceeding it was
called contesting the election and there
were many Republicans and I'm talking
about mainstream Republic an Ted Cruz
and others they were going to challenge
Arizona Georgia Michigan Wisconsin they
were going to challenge the election in
the swing States yeah that is the
process that somebody wanted to stop the
Democrats they didn't want the
questioning of the election to occur so
think about it January 6th was actually
not what the trumpsters wanted the
trumpers wanted the opposite they wanted
the questioning of the election to
continue and yet the moment that you had
January 6th the Republicans were so sort
of downcast and ejected that they came
right back and they're like okay forget
about all that let's just certify Biden
so January 6 was a bonanza for the left
and and and I think by twisting that
history um we got the false narrative
that has been one-sidedly promulgated by
the January 6 committee well so let me
let me dive in kind of off of that
because you had a lot of people
questioning whether there were feds
involved with January 6 were they just
embedded were they there trying to stop
potential plots I understand that you've
got a very large crowd in Washington
you've got a very charged atmosphere
you've got a very kind of charismatic
president uh who has lost an election in
in in their eyes but has basically been
cheated out of an election in most of
his followers eyes um we never really
got answers as to how many federal
agents were involved with that because
there were people like Ray EPs and I
know that some stuff has happened with
him that was kind of a lightning rod for
it because there's film there's footage
of him saying we're going to go to the
capital and people are like fed fed this
guys a Fed right and he's seen there
whispering to somebody right before they
start doing so with these agencies do
you think that we should defund the FBI
and some of the other agencies
potentially let's start with the FBI and
not lump them in with other people
because you can think about this and yes
please comment below and let me know
what you would you you think do we
defund the FBI and and if we do what
should we put in its place well these
agencies have become uh rotted uh
through and through now that itself
requires a little bit of explanation
because it's a bit of a puzzle many
people who go into the FBI are
conservative they are guys with a
military background yeah they're
patriotic guys so it's it's not correct
to say that kind of an evil force has
taken over the FBI from top to bottom
that makes no sense in fact no police
state functions that way the genius of
every police state is it figures out how
to make good people do really bad things
yeah so let's look at a really bad thing
an FBI agent at 5:30 in the morning
smashes the apartment of a 70-year-old
grandmother who let's say went into the
capital for 15 minutes yeah goes up to
her she resists so he grabs her by the
hair twists her arms behind her back
puts the handcuffs on her she resists
some more so he pulls her down the
stairs out into the street her neighbors
come out and gawk at her they're like oh
my God the woman is just absolutely
destroyed and humiliated so what would
cause a nice guy a decent guy with a
family lives in a three-bedroom house to
do this I think I can answer that
question and that is what the what
police states do is they they
operationalize or bureaucratize the task
at hand they they never say what the
ultimate goal is they merely Define a
sort of a project um a few weeks ago I
was watching a documentary on Waco yeah
and they were they they were talking to
the FBI they call him a hostage
negotiator but he's basically a killer
he's a sniper yeah and and he goes yeah
listen when all else fails they bring me
in right and the interview asked him
they go hey you know did you know who
David Kesh was did you know anything
about Waco about the people in there the
branch devidians he goes no he goes when
I come in they just point and tell me
there's a bad guy there's an enemy of
Truth and Justice and the American way
take out your long rifle kill that guy
and so this guy is like a soldier you
know so he defines his task as he is
serving his country he's doing a good
job he will get a bonus and a promotion
if he carries out his duty and his duty
as defined here is take out that bad guy
so I think what happens with the police
state is that you've got good guys who
get the idea that hey the FBI is not
that interested right now in child
trafficking they're not interested right
now in even the old style Mafia stuff
that made them famous they're interested
in domestic
extremists um and and you if you want to
be cool with the FBI you want to be part
of the In Crowd you want to get a nice
bonus at the end of the year you don't
want to be seen as a troublemaker you
want to retire with a nice pension this
is what you do don't ask your don't
worry about the grandmother the courts
will deal with her your job is just to
apprehend her and this is how we do it
well and Trust in the institutions that
are here that have I mean historically
maybe they've never been completely
trustworthy but as Americans we have had
a lot more trust in our institutions
than we have in the last say 20 years
um some of the wool has been kind of
pulled over eyes I think for a long time
but now we're thinking like okay wait a
minute maybe we can't just give blind
trust to this I remember you made me
think of something like how do normal
people end up doing horrible things well
it it's happened it happened in Germany
in that example do you think that that
they were a more murderous people like
that Germans wanted to go and kill
innocent people men women and children
no they weren't more murderous than
their neighbors were it happened to
there for a very specific set of reasons
and it shows you that populations can
turn into these very kind of evil things
um I remember in high school I asked my
professor because he was talking to me
about ancient history is a history
professor and it was talking about the
Assyrians and they would do public
peelings and public dismals to keep
people in line these communities that
they had conquered and I just thought to
myself like how do these guys go home
and he goes no I know like these
soldiers go home to their wife they go
home to their kids and they've done
these barbaric things to them and he
says are they do you think they loved it
no I I I don't think that that's the
easy answer that we can just apply to
every everybody it was in service of the
state you you can't just convince people
to do bad things Hamas is a really good
example of this I think as well and
obviously we've had that issue uh that
happened a little while ago with the the
Gaza hospital and all the stuff that had
come out there like oh well actually
Hamas lied right that that the hospital
wasn't hit it was the parking lot that
was hit and it was actually one of the
the missiles being fired by the Islamic
uh Jihad which is kind of the again the
basic name of jihad like all of them are
Islamic and all them Jihad they didn't
really put a lot of effort into The
Branding there they just kind of went
with the most basic title and you're
seeing what happens is you're convincing
people that this is in service to
something greater than yourself and
these are the enemies they're trusting
in the Islamic leadership in Hamas right
they're trusting like these are enemies
of us trust me this is what God wants
you to do the Assyrians are trusting in
their leadership saying trust me if we
don't do this to these populations they
will try and overthrow us and kill you
and your family and so they put that on
the chopping block and I think what's
happening right now in the United States
is conservatives are the enemy because
they don't care about you co kind of
laid some of the groundwork for that it
continued it and they're not interested
in having free and fair elections
they're interested in installing a
dictator in Donald Trump and so in the
film you talk quite a bit about
President Trump um and what's been going
on and kind of alluding to him in
different parts of the film um with the
FBI we talked about maybe getting rid of
that let me let me go Circle back to
that before I get to Trump because
that'll lead us down another path
if if that's
true how do we get rid of the rot right
you've got like you said probably a
bunch of good people working at the FBI
hardworking Americans that love their
country that want to serve their country
that aren't the bad guys but you've
apparently got a lot of people in
positions of power that are wielding
that power in a very corrupt way how do
we solve that problem because this is
what your film highlights and we want to
know Solutions this isn't and I don't
think you're here to say just go watch
the movie and be out outraged with me
and maybe tell a few of your friends
about it but it's a solution so what's
the solution to the FBI yeah I mean the
solution to the FBI is really the same
as the solution to any institution that
has been corrupted in this way I mean
this would apply for example to a
University faculty if you think about
how you take over a university by the
left it is that they take over the key
faculty committees that hire people uh
and so they're able to self- perpet
then they're powerful that they get Veto
power over the presid so that even if
the of Tres goes we got this business
guy we want to bring him in they're like
no he's not he's not confirmed on the
left you know find somebody else exactly
right so so you have to dismantle that
power structure you don't have to I
don't think you have to burn the FBI
building that's not going to do anything
you have to identify the key areas crime
D we can't do that no no no you know of
course you know what I mean is take down
the bill people are like you know you've
got to take the down from the top to the
bottom no what I'm getting at is what we
need to do is identify where these
corrupt centers of Power are dismantle
those and then create a healthy
structure of incentives where people
really want to do the kind of fair law
enforcement work the FBI was set up to
do so in that sense the institution can
be reformed but reform normally suggests
just some kind of cosmetic change like
changing the director no that will not
do it you have to burrow down into the
bureaucracy um a point about that really
struck me was I think this phenomenon
about sort of boasting about your
brutality is something that goes even
beyond the Nazis I mean this seems
ridiculous to say right because people
will say you can't compare it to the
Nazis I think this is actually a
comparison in favor of the Nazis if I
can put it that way because think about
it when the Nazis established death
camps not the concentration camps
because concentration camps were labor
camps but death camps were gas Chambers
right how can you systematically
eradicate a people in the most efficient
way possible and you'll notice that not
a single death camp is in Germany right
every death camp is in Poland or the
occupied territories now why is that
because the Nazis didn't want to show it
no to the Germans they were not in that
sense proud of what they were doing and
so that is a little different from
sometimes this terrorist exhibitionism
that we see these days where a terrorist
group Revels in the amount of Carnage
that they've caused almost as if that is
a measure of their
effectiveness uh and that is really what
Thrills the sort of terrorist Lobby all
over the world wow who would have
thought Hamas could get into Israel with
a thousand guys coming to you know
imaginatively from the sky um and then
just you know having their way with them
it struck me that you know that even
though the Nazi analogy can be overdone
in this case we might even be seeing
things that are in some senses worse
yeah well and I think it's the The
Crossing of all the things that we've
been talking about are the intersection
with that and obviously religion right
and so it kind of brings an entirely new
level of commitment from people who are
committed to uh a religion and so I I
think um interestingly you know I think
you've got the right point on the FBI I
think it needs to be defunded like we've
talked about like taking it down to the
studs I think there needs to be
something like that done uh with them to
to get an agency because you need them
you need some kind of an agency to serve
a some of the functions right because
you've got investigating terrorism
you've got drugs and human trafficking
you've got a lot of like legitimate
functions that the FBI can serve but you
don't need the FBI so my my next
question I guess will lead into Donald
Trump because if if you let's say that
Trump gets elected president Trump he's
leading in all the polls right now in
the primary nobody's ever lost with the
kind of lead he's had right we'll talk
about a few things maybe that are
potentials for him if he gets back in
and disbands the FBI do you think the
left is going to view that as a
correction or as an authoritarian move
meaning the kind of disbanding that
we've talked about like okay we have to
really dig down in and get the rot out
of the FBI do you think they're going to
see that as a correction or as see we
told you he's going to be authoritarian
he's never going to leave office again
the left will absolutely see it that way
they will see it as Trump is now
wreaking Vengeance on the people who
tried to get him uh and and and to some
degree I think that perception is going
to be unavoidable
I'm actually not so worried about that
right now I'm more worried about the
Republican
psychology that the right of Center
psychology that doesn't recognize the
sort of peril that we are in as a
country with regard to our basic rights
when it comes to the FBI for example I
would say that one half of Republican
members of Congress are going to be
immediately Frozen when you bring up the
topic because they're like wait a minute
we thought we were back the blue how can
we be back the blue and at the same time
against the FBI this is going to be too
confusing a message for my constituents
toes and I'm like wait a minute police
states are inherently Lawless the what
the FBI is doing is abusing its
credibility and its in its prosecutorial
discretion and its in the intelligence
function it was set up to do it's
abusing all of that so there's nothing
inconsistent with being backed the blue
and supporting Law and Order and then
opposing the abuse of Law and Order so
but but Republicans in in this sense are
very reluctant to modify traditional
positions that really go back to the
Reagan Era but in I think are obsolete
today so the difference is I don't know
if you've seen The Man Who Shot Liberty
Balance but in the beginning you got
Jimmy Stewart he's a goofball guy he's a
Law and Order guy and he's like I'm not
going to be like these criminals you
know I'm I I rely on my books and I'll
call the I'll call the authorities if I
need to I feel living in a peaceful town
with a good sheriff and a good system
you can be that way focus on your books
but if you go out in a covered wagon out
west and you're surrounded by Outlaws
with guns and they want to burn your
homestead and rape your wife and kill
your kids and you're like I'm not going
to go for my rifle because I'm better
than they are I'm a man of principle you
know you dead man of principle you would
be and nobody would even know what to
say to you and and so that's kind of
what my film is intended to say is
listen we are not in noral politics in
America we are seeing in a very short
time rights that we took for granted
really since the founding being
seriously imperiled and the forces that
are doing this I mean they're in
Academia they're in the media they're in
the nonprofit sector they are the
digital platforms they're in government
I mean you're dealing with a very
formidable combination of forces so this
is not even something that is fixed by
an election it it it's going to take an
election but a lot more it's going to
definitely take a lot more and look the
only reason we get to do this kind of
stuff and the only reason we exist is
because of mug clubs so do consider
joining mug club for 89 bucks a year uh
it's how we do everything that we do you
get all of the uh shows that you see
here you also get our Friday show that
we had we have Nick depalo we have Alex
Jones uh we have Brian Ken uh we've got
the Hodge twins doing a show now we've
got Mr Guns & Gear keeping you informed
on all of your second amendment rights
and all of the different guns uh that
are out there but then we have our
undercover unit and we have lot of the
campaigns that we're kind of standing up
to really fight back in a lot of ways
instead of just talking to you about
this stuff kind of like Des you know
like it's not just about talking about
these issues and going all right I sold
another book or I got another movie deal
it's about actually getting something
done and I think for us we've we
developed mug Club specifically because
of the censorship uh censorship that
we've kind of fought through with big
Tech um specifically YouTube right and
dealt with a lot of things and we we
deal with it all the time but it goes
goes back to the Vox apocalypse where
you know Susan wijit was talking about
Steven and saying he didn't break any
rules but we're going to make some new
rules so that that way it's taken care
of and we can just kind of say he broke
some rules and so now he's demonetized
and his reach is limited and he's
throttled and he's got a strike on his
account so he can't talk about the 2022
midterms because we had Carrie Lake on
the show I get a a strike because I
quoted the California CDC where four out
of the last 10 years uh the flu was more
deadly for children at the time this was
this was California information the flu
was more dead deadly four of the last 10
seasons than Co was at the time right
and we were just talking through those
things or even the the laptop the hunter
Biden laptop that was apparently Russian
disinformation um we fight that same
fight and I think you're right people
don't really know that but here's here's
one case where I think a lot of people
will come together and go yeah this
doesn't quite seem right and that's
president Trump this is this is playing
out in front of our eyes and you can
feel about him however you want to feel
you can think that he's Brash you can
think that he's a mean Tweeter or exer
or poster I'm not even sure what they
call it anymore with the name change
here you can think that uh he's not the
most moral man that you've ever met he's
made some very bad comments about people
he pic what whatever you want to think
about him he was very effective liberals
we showed you that clip a while back of
the uh liberal billionaire uh part owner
I think of the the Golden State nuggets
that came out and said we shot the
message because we didn't like the
messenger like that he was talking about
building a wall and we didn't like that
he was talking about building a wall so
we didn't and now we're dealing with all
of the consequences so you're starting
to see people change a little bit even
on the left do you think what's
happening with President Trump right now
first off tell talk maybe just a little
bit about what you think is going on
here and do you think that's enough of a
wake-up call for people across the
entire Spectrum uh of Americans to maybe
go wait a minute the Deep State really
is a thing the police state really is a
thing well well I think that there are
some people on the left who are they're
so discombobulated by the very name
Trump and this is because of the
Relentless engine of propaganda and
indoctrination that they they're not
able to look at this issue objectively
at all in fact the only they would way
they would see it objectively is if you
change the name of the country and you
change the name of the man and you said
you know in Poland there's this man
let's just call him Donald trumpski you
know and the opposition party has
arrested him and he's the leading
candidate of the other party and they
haven't just put a single criminal
charge on him for something obvious like
oh you know what he was found with
suitcases of money that came from you
know that would actually be Biden yeah I
say you're describing someone else now
right exactly so but we're he's hit with
90 plus charges I think people would get
it right away the US government would be
would be calling that country a Banana
Republic and Human Rights Watch would be
all over it so look with Trump if they
had mounted a single charge and they had
said all right Trump you took these
classified documents now we asked you
for them back but you're a stubborn guy
and you're like I'm not giving them back
and so you know we're going to put a
single criminal charge on you to sort of
uh convey the seriousness of this matter
we would be like let's look at the facts
let's look at the merits of it but when
you have this blizzard of charges this
shotgun approach where it's like listen
you know if we can't get you in DC we'll
get you in Florida can't get you in
Florida how about Georgia uh if it's not
a federal case our Soros funded State
Das will move in if you can't get you in
Georgia you know in New York and if we
can't get you on the criminal case we'll
wreck your business with a civil case
right I mean this is police state
thuggery as naked as it comes and I
think it is because they do fear that
Trump is the most dangerous opponent the
police state I think it's because he is
the least Bound by political convention
you know any other Republican will
quickly fall into line if you say you're
not allowed to talk about firing civil
servants you know you're not allowed to
say that the justice department is an
extension of the executive branch you're
not allowed to call up Kim Jong-un on
the phone if you go to a meeting you're
supposed to president come on he can do
these things well this is what makes
Trump unique right any other any other
president that met with let's just say
Kim Jong-un would come out and say we
had a very meaningful dialogue we we
made significant progress on human
rights where Trump comes out he goes you
know uh I asked him you know what does
he think of his nickname Rocket Man you
know and then and then I told him he's
like what's Rocket Man I gave him a CD
you know and he was he was really short
but you know he laughed a lot I mean
Trump actually tells you what it's
actually like to be in the room right
and this is why I think there are people
in this country who aren't actually all
that political in their bones but they
identify with Trump because he has this
kind of normal way ofis surprising for a
billionaire kind of popular very
well-known worldwide guy he's he kind of
I almost was going to say he has a
little bit of an Everyman kind of
personality in some ways um or at least
he says things that he's we're thinking
he says what we want somebody to say in
response like you know Hillary I would
have locked you up you know that that
kind of thing really resonated with a
lot of people like that's right
don't be nice go after these people well
Trump Trump's dad used to say to him you
know we're not Manhattan we're queens
and this is really important because
Trump although he grew up rich he grew
up rich sort of in the outer Burrows of
New York uh his dad had you know rent
control apartments that he was uh you
know they made money that way and
Manhattan to them was a different place
uh Trump still has some of that yeah and
I think that's what people identify with
yeah yeah so let me we'll go right back
to Trump in just a second but of the
other candidates right now if let's just
imagine a world where Donald Trump is
not running uh for president in 2024 who
else of the candidates that we have now
would be capable or at least willing to
go after the police state in your mind
in in my mind there would be of of the
rest of them only two um I think I can
guess but tell me tell me who I say I
would say I would say DeSantis and and
Vic V yeah those two V sorry VI like
cake he was in here we did an interview
with him recently and that was how he
did it yes those are the two that I
would think as well so with Ronda santis
obviously because of his kind of track
record as governor of Florida we've been
very you know we've had a lot of praise
for Ronda santis until his campaign
started and then he got a little bit he
he it seems like he fell into the mold
of past Republican candidates that kind
of distance themselves from Trump just a
little bit they were like uh don't run
away from what made you great as
Governor just be that guy he also did
not defend Trump where it was completely
appropriate to defend Trump I think that
was a serious judgment error I also
think that you know if I were Trump and
and I sailed through to the
nomination the first thing I would do
even though I don't think this is what
Trump will do is I would call Ron de
santis yeah and I would tell him
Ron um I can bring the the the big
personality and the Charisma and I'm
maybe the guy that the Republican base
and the country can identify with
because I speak a normal language but
you do have a ruthless operational
efficiency that you brought to Florida
that we need in the federal government
in other words I'm going to ask you to
go into the FBI burrow into the
bureaucracy and root out the corruption
and then I want you to do that to se
seven other institutions so s DeSantis
would have a tremendous amount of scope
and power but so in other words I guess
what I'm saying is politically I think
that there's a there's a complimentary
set of strengths that disantis and Trump
bring to the table and Vic has a lot of
strengths as well and vivec has done
some of the things right that DeSantis
hasn't which is why VI has gotten more
traction than one would have expected
yeah and he's he's seen kind of as an
outsider he's a CEO he's a businessman
he's succeeded he he he really follows
that Trump model quite a bit except he
seems very polished and Trump was very
Brash V seems a little bit more kind of
Polished in that regard um but he he is
kind of like if Donald Trump is not
running and you're looking for that he
seems to embody that more than any other
candidate I guess the the next question
is we were only to able to name
two why I mean is it just that you know
and and I like Tim Scott um I I know
Nikki Haley has been a part of a lot of
this stuff are these people too close to
the forest for the trees are they
basically not seeing the problem not
capable of fighting against the problem
because they're I guess beholden I don't
know well my reading of it is that they
are still living in the Reagan Era yeah
and and I say this as someone who I mean
I my political formation is in the
Reagan Era yeah uh I went to college at
Dartmouth when Reagan was first running
for president and and so it was that
appreciation of Reagan as kind of an
embodiment of American idealism someone
who um understood the issues and but um
Reagan was a president when the main
problem was abroad you know it was the
Cold War the threat was communism in
Russia us that's right now we are in a
kind of a domestic Cold War uh with a
very no less sort of fanatical adversary
to be honest and we need people who
recognize that the world has changed I
mean it goes back really to even the
Republican Party in the 1850s was
completely incapable of recognizing in
the perilous situation facing the
country part of the genius of Lincoln
was that even though he came out of the
moderate wing of the party you would
almost say he was a kind of rhino in his
own day yeah um when he came to
Washington he recognized immediately
that the Democratic party had become
gangsterizm clay style compromises and
constantly appeasing these guys was not
going to work and so l you could be
describing the last 20 years right now
easily maybe even a little bit more than
that but those the whole okay we'll just
pacify it's always the Republican fault
it's always the Democrats we the highway
on these bills and we get pushed around
even when we have majorities right
exactly I how but no I mean you take
Mike Pence and it's one thing you know I
even agree with Mike Pence when he says
all right I'm the vice president my task
um on that day was sort of custodial and
ceremonial I don't think I had the
constitutional authority to just push
the election back to the States maybe
he's right about that but someone like
that has got to address the larger issue
which is to say was there systematic
fraud in this election that needs some
sort of attention maybe you're not the
guy to do it maybe that was not the time
or the place but to just say that one
thing and then punt right exactly and
and I think that's the sputtering
frustration of the Republican base and
this is really why people went to DC on
January 6th it's like who is going to
look at this mean who is going to look
at this substantively not not some local
court that goes Hey listen you may or
may not be right but you should have
brought this challenge before the
election and then if you brought the
challenge before the election hey you
may or may not be right but listen the
election hasn't even happened so why you
why you why are you suing over imaginary
crimes that haven't yet occurred so this
kind of evasiveness I think drove the
just the the Primal scream that became
January 6th yeah absolutely and and it's
frustrating because those are the kinds
of things that lead to actual when
people talk like are we at the level of
Civil War the the answer we've given
people is no but you're at the point
where you have to fight for your country
in different ways you have to elect good
leaders you have to be aware of what's
going on you have to push back on States
or or State Police kind of um thing not
sorry not individual states gosh
sometimes your brain just kind of mixes
words together the police state not the
state police staties they're fine what
I'm talking about is you have to be
aware of what's going on and engaged in
that fight and that's I think what
Donald Trump was saying as president
saying look you're going to have to
fight like hell to keep he wasn't saying
take to the streets with weapons he was
saying get engaged in this process and
you know you just listed out a lot of
the challenges that were kind of the
governmental issues like I have a
problem with how the state is handling
this election you mentioned the hunter
Biden lap top as well and that alone now
that's that's the crossing of business
and state where you get the state
telling businesses this is Russian
disinformation there's there's obviously
studies I'm sure you've seen them too
that that would have changed the outcome
of the election just that one thing
alone based on the polling that they
have done would have changed the outcome
of the election period none of the other
cases needed to be brought now they're
serious and we need to get to the bottom
of those things but that is the scariest
I think part for me is that like you
said in your your film it's the state
now kind of getting these private
companies to do their bidding Facebook
well meta now X thankfully has been
purchased by Elon Musk and so it feels
like a bit of a safe haven for free
speech even though it's not perfect and
I don't like that he put Linda Yaro in
power there from you know NBC Universal
days um but other places like Google
still seem like the the wild west they
can kind of do whatever they want and
manipulate elections so I I think in one
of your uh interviews here with Zack is
it Vorhees is the Google whistleblower
he describes Google as a quasi State
actor how how do we break up that
relationship right so we've covered the
government we've covered the
three-letter agencies now we're getting
into the business side of this how do we
deal with that section of it and and
what did you find out I guess in doing
well the the the the if we had
legislative power which we don't have
because to do that you need both
branches of both the house and the
Senate and you also need to have the
presidency you could very easily break
up Google under the antitrust laws I
mean Google is a is an obvious Monopoly
you can argue whether meta Facebook's a
monopoly uh YouTube is not a monopoly
but Google is a monopoly um and uh
however you can strike that down in one
shot right now with the Supreme Court
ruling because and and there is by the
way the case of Missouri versus Biden
making its way up the courts okay and
the the Attorneys General of Missouri
and Louisiana along with others have
exposed that this censorship and it's
worth zooming in on it for a little bit
because because the censorship involves
so many different institutions this is
typically how it works you have some
academic and a lot of these academics
have nothing better to do so what they
do is they monitor social media people
like you and me and Steven Crowder and
they go okay we're going to list the 50
greatest spreaders of disinformation in
the country okay so let's just say Okay
Crowder is on the list I'm on the list
and now what happens is the academic
provides this list which is then picked
up by the Biden Administration and and
sorted so they'll say well Crowder is
spreading disinformation about about
coid so that goes to the CDC right denes
is spreading misinformation about the
2020 election so that goes to the group
called cisa the cyber security
infrastructure agency so you've got like
40 agencies of the government collecting
this stuff and all making lists but they
don't want to go to the digital
platforms directly why because it's too
obviously censorship it's like flat ly
forbidden in the First Amendment so they
hire a middleman they go to the Stanford
internet Observatory or another group
called the virality project and there
are other groups like this and they go
hey guys listen we'll give you the list
you walk over to Google you walk over to
meta you deliver the list so when they
censor people our grubby hands are not
our fingerprints are not on the list and
so the nonprofit becomes ultimately The
Courier and then the digital platform
carries it out to the Applause of the
media so look at all the different
institutions involved the Academia is
involved uh the media is involved the
digital platforms are involved multiple
agencies of government but the good
thing is that in the Missouri versus
Biden case they are onto this and
they've got all this discovery showing
exactly how this works and it's making
its way upward well the Supreme Court
just needs to come in and say listen not
only is government censorship forbidden
but censorship by surrogate is equally
forbidden of course right and it's it's
so clearcut uh and see this is how you
fight a police state you don't just
fight a police state by saying you know
what can the ordinary citizen do the
ordinary citizen can do some things like
become a pole Watcher become an election
Observer there are 10 things you can do
but we also need institutions to act the
courts the Republican uh house uh uh you
know certainly Republican Governors
Attorneys General secretaries of State
states can do a lot states can do a lot
right and so and what we saw in a lot of
the last you know last few elections was
maybe a move in that direction where
we're getting more governorships and
we're getting more control of state
legislatures and saying okay hey these
changes can be made at the state level
and that's a very important thing so
maybe that's okay so one of the things
that you can do is to make sure that you
are informed in state elections make
sure that you're not just a every
two-year person where you're going to
vote in the general and then you're
going to vote uh to to maybe do the
midterms and see you know okay I'm going
to get ramped up about this every two
years that's the only amount of time
that I can spend and look I know I'm
asking a lot of you to go out and spend
extra time that you don't necessarily
have I'm in the same boat other than I
do this for a living and so maybe it's a
little easier for me to stay in tune
with what's going on but it's important
it's very important and it's not one of
my one of my final questions for you and
just a few minutes here is going to be
related to this it's not just about
doing a show it's not just about doing
an interview Des it's been fantastic I'm
learning a whole lot of stuff here but
it's about making an impact when we did
the interview with Dr Robert Epstein
about Google are you familiar with I am
I have just had him on my podcast oh so
you know some of the things that just
make you go are you kidding me he can
Google can flip a 50/50 into a a 9010
just by search uh manipulation like that
that's insane it's about figuring out a
way to take the information that you
have and then go okay how do I fix this
how do I become part of the solution to
this how do I work proactively and for
parents with kids in school get involved
in school boards and ptas make sure that
you're electing good people that are
going to have control over what's going
on in those institutions fantastic there
we go state governments can help kind of
buttress the election system if you
don't like how the elections were
handled guess what state lawmakers a lot
of times were behind some of that stuff
saying okay well we'll go aad and allow
these mailin ballots and we'll allow
ballot harvesting we'll allow all this
stuff so help you make a change there
it's not always just the people that we
send off to Congress so that's something
that you can do and by the way really
quickly just comment below do you know
anybody who uses anything other than
Google to search I don't know what their
market share is off the top of my head
but I think it's somewhere in the '90s
percentage wise I mean there are a
couple of search engines but they are
they're not even I mean that's why we
use Google as a verb Google it I know it
has become a thing right and I think
Duck Duck Go is one of the the
competitors to that but most people that
you know so if if really what we're
talking about is you've got this police
state who is you know and we're waiting
on cases to be decided but I think
that's what led me into what I just said
is that I get so frustrated because it's
like aha we've got it but then nothing
happens and we've had so many of those
moments as conservatives where we're
like ah okay well I thought we had it
nothing happened nothing's changed
nothing's fixed what are we doing how is
it going to get fixed I want people to
have some small wins along the way to
keep them going for the bigger wins that
we're waiting for in Supreme Court cases
and things like that one of the things
just jumped in my mind and it's it's a
little out of sequence because it goes
back to the very first question you
asked me about the film reaching out to
people on the other side I think one of
the things the film does well is it
tells you the genealogy the origin of
the police state and this is a little
bit of an embarrassment because the
origin of the police state is not only
bipartisan but somewhat Republican it is
it's yeah it's the Patriot Act well what
happened is after 911 right there was a
a wave of fear that goes through the
country and fear is always politically
problematic because it's makes you do
things you wouldn't otherwise do correct
and a lot of people me included I'm
sorry to say were like okay uh we don't
just chase down these crimes after they
occur we got to stop the next one
everybody wanted that everyone wanted
that nobody wanted to be the the the
victim of the next crime and everybody
thought it was coming right around the
corner right so let's give all this
enhanced surveillance power and let's
break down some of the barriers between
intelligence on the one hand and
criminal investigation on the other
let's Empower these police agencies of
the US government but obviously with the
intention of going after the foreign
terrorist in fact going after people
like these Hamas guys so so why do you
think us intelligence missed this
completely right and I think the answer
is focused on white guys in Suburban
America what yeah so what happened was
that even though the police state traces
its roots to the bush era I think that
the
politicization the the Turning of the
camera inward the aiming it at domestic
political opponent
it began under Obama and was ramped up
dramatically under Biden yeah well I
mean it's still the jover building like
you still got the building named after a
guy who was known for these kinds of
tactics that we're talking about in a
police state like trying to trying to
convince Martin Luther King to to kill
himself like like just these really
really bad things so that makes me think
like man was it always this way and it
just had enough guard rails at the time
to kind of keep it from going completely
crazy or was it always crazy and we just
never really knew about it because we
didn't have access to social media and
all the citizen journalism that we have
today and all the people pushing back
yeah I I think it has changed and the
reason I say this is there's a big
difference between a power hungry
megalomaniac like Hoover who wanted to
have kind of a personal I've got
something on everybody right and but but
see Jay Edgar Hoover would never dream
of interfering in the Nixon Kennedy
election of 1960 he wasn't trying to put
his finger on the scale he wasn't trying
to tyrannically run the country from his
back office in the Hoover you know in
the FBI building he just wanted frankly
he wanted to secure his own position in
power which is corrupt but it's not the
same as the ideological corruption that
we're seeing now somebody made the same
point about anti-Semitism it was a
former Ambassador David fredman he goes
listen you can find anti-Semitism a lot
of places but he goes if you want to
find a fullscale ideology that justifies
anti-Semitism that commands support even
in mainstream institutions he goes
That's coming from the left yeah well so
I think I think we've covered most of
the bases I would highly recommend that
you go and watch the film um again it's
going to be in theaters on got it here
in my notes on October 23rd and 25th go
to police state film. net but before we
go kind of my final question and denes
this is more about on the right
sometimes we get people who dance on the
line and this is not an accusation I'm
hurling against you so be clear that's
not where I'm going of being kind of a
quote unquote grifter right somebody who
is basically just like how can I make
money off of this movement and you've
you've written a lot of books you you
and I were talking about like this what
you're doing right now with these
documentaries and I love really well
done it's not quite a documentary it's
more than that I don't know if there's
actually a name it's a movie that kind
of functions as a documentary as well
there's so much more that you've put
into it than just going and asking
somebody questions and throwing some
b-roll footage behind you right um I
love those things I love it when they're
well done because they educate the
audience but how do you address people
who say okay we're we're just going to
buy another ticket to a movie right is
denes really interested in this like
where's your heart behind this like
really tell us like what what what do
you want to have happen why are you so
focused on doing this not just with this
movie but with everything that you're
doing I think that uh well just a word
about the documentaries some people call
the my films a docu drama because I try
to put in non-fiction film all the
ingredients that make a feature film
great so there's suspense there's a plot
storyline there is a movement toward a
climax and you have a you want to leave
the audience with a sense of
Enlightenment but also galvanized to
action so those are some of the elements
in putting a film together now what
motivates me uh documentaries a very
hard genre and they're they're very very
hard on the right they're not so hard on
the left here's what I mean if Michael
Moore wants to make a film what does he
do he goes to a studio and he says give
me $10 million and they go here he makes
the film uh and then the moment he's
finished his job is done the studio says
all right we're you're going to be on
The View tomorrow you're going to be on
Steven Co bear Bill Mah has you on we
got this we got that you know so what
I'm getting at is the only thing Michael
Moore does is the film nothing else
everything else is done for him the
whole infrastructure is there on the
right lots of people are making
documentaries and and they find it's
really hard why because you need some
legal expertise and you need to raise
money really hard to do yeah and even if
you're able to raise money you then have
to figure out how do I make a good film
really hard to do also because a lot of
people on our side think films are just
about messaging and they're like dises
do some messaging make a film on a the B
water on Obamacare and I'm like how do I
get people to get out of their home and
get in the car go to a theater to watch
a film it's all messaging you know and
but once you make a good film you then
have to Market it so what happens is and
you have to be really good at all those
things now the business model I
developed going back to my first film
was I go to some investors uh
conservative investors who by and large
are not used to funding films they're
used to funding elections and I said
guys if you give me some money I will
work really hard in the market to get it
back to you so you can turn around and
give it back to me to make my next film
in other words I said I'm going to call
this recycled philanthropy I'd like to
make some money for you but that's not
important to to you or to me our goal is
the cause but I'm trying to create a
self you know I don't like being the guy
who's hitting up people for donations
all the time so I want to create a
mechanism in which I can produce a
product in the market then work really
hard to return the investment to my
investors in the full understanding that
our job is to now do it again do it
again do it again so that's really
what's driving me and my complete focus
is on on saving the country because I
mean you got to remember I came here at
the age of 17 my whole life has been
shaped by America I've you know written
books like what's so great about America
if you ask me today is America a free
country I would I would want I believe
no but I wouldn't want to say that I
would be embarrassed to say it right so
we are in this very awkward position and
and those of us who are Rah American
immigrants ANS uh have some obligation I
think to give back to the country that
has given us so much uh and that's what
motivates me yeah no that that's good I
and I can see that a lot of people that
we talk to that didn't grow up here for
some period of time and then came to
America just like oh my gosh like this
is this is worth fighting for this is
worth keeping it's it's going the way
and I know you interviewed I always
forget her name but she grew up in North
Korea Yan me Park yes right and so she
spots it very clearly the the refugees
from Cuba they spot it very clearly
saying hey uh this country is going the
way of some of these other regimes and
you guys need to be you need to be a
little bit more aware of what's going on
I mean if I can say one one thing about
Yan me is every time I see her this is
the thought that goes through my head
that there's for a for a country in a
situation like we are now there is a
window of time Yan me actually has a
book called while time remains which is
to me a haunting title it because what
she's saying is the time is not
unlimited because if the jaws of the
police state snap shut then the only
thing we can do is run right I mean get
out get your family out get your money
out um your options become much more
limited so yeah if you ask me in one
sentence why I made this movie it's so
we never get to that point because we
have the time to to to block to thwart
even to roll back the police state it's
not going to be easy but we can do it
and we have the obligation to do what we
can while time remains yeah absolutely
well look I I think it's very important
go see police state film uh October 23rd
and 25th in theaters policestate fm.net
to get your tickets that's the only
place to do it if you can't get out into
the theater make sure you go to the
virtual premiere on October 27th uh it's
going to be from Las Vegas with some Q&A
from you and our friend Dan Bonino uh
denes thank you very much for all the
work that you're doing on this I really
appreciate it and for answering some of
the questions I want to make sure if
anybody out there as asking the question
why is denesh doing this is it just
another is it a messaging film or
something like that there really is a
goal um right now that we're trying to
save the country that's that's what we
talk about we're trying to save what we
believe is the greatest country on Earth
that has fallen on hard times that is
definitely culturally not in the right
place and uh administratively right now
is also not in the right place so
whoever whoever that person is for you
um that you are looking at to come in
and save the day it's bigger than one
person it's not just president Trump
like we have to win a lot of Elections
and we have to do a lot of hard work and
unfortunately that's what it takes to
keep this country that we all love and
uh to remake it in the image that our
Founders saw it being made into right
and so we've we've got a lot of work to
do but that's okay we we have time right
now and as a Christian you know the
Bible has some of that similar language
like go out while the time is available
like while it's still day and work can
be done well we're in that same place uh
as America while it is still light and
this work is possible to be done we have
to go out we have to do that work uh
make sure you guys tune in back again
with us tomorrow we'll be here uh 10:00
a.m. eastern but make sure you go and
support this work go and support Desh uh
in the theaters and uh hopefully Des
will you won't have to make many more of
these hopefully there'll be a lot of
work that is done and the problem will
get solved and we won't have to keep
doing this but as many as are necessary
we would always love to have you back
we'd love to talk about this and some of
the success uh that hopefully you will
have from this but uh thank you for
being with us today and joining us and
uh thank you to all of you for
supporting us for supporting mug club
and making all of this happen it has
been a pleasure and we will see you
[Music]
[Applause]
tomorrow what I
know
change
got